Simon Cowell promises to buy a young AGT
contestant a dog if he nails the
audition and only i'm with mel b's
15-year old golden buzzer plus fans
flock to pay tribute to late rapper XXX
10th us young hello friends this is the
daily denny and it is wednesday which
means we need to talk about America's
Got Talent
do you guys watch if not let me catch
you up 13 year old Jeffrey Lee came to
AGT to pursue his dream of singing
little did he know there was also
another big prize at stake what would
you do with a million dollars I'm the
only child so I would love a companion
um I guess I guess a dog if you do well
I'm gonna buy you a dog
okay choose one together that's right
Simon Cowell upped the ante with that
offer and lucky for Jeffrey he told he
nailed his audition hitting all the high
notes on a Josh Groban classic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right oh boy Geoffrey made it
through to the next round but the big
question is will assignment make good on
his word and get the boy a dog he says
he will so we'll just have to wait and
see
alright meanwhile another showstopper
last night came courtesy of Amanda Nina
the 15 year old singer went from being
bullied in school to earning that
coveted golden buzzer from lb with this
insane Aretha Franklin cover and I heard
all about it
[Music]
walking back to that moment what was
going through your mind when mal reached
over and hit that golden buzzer I really
couldn't believe it like I I kind of
blacked out for a second I was like what
is happening it was real life that was
just incredible what do you think it is
about you that she connected to the most
I think we both believe in the same
similar things like empowerment for
young women amanda says she was bullied
when she was younger and hopes for music
inspires kids just like her I got made
fun of a lot that really hurt
if you could say anything to your
bullies now what would you say I don't
want to say thank you
because they taught me a lot and the
experiences that I had before right now
I can deal with it better there's a lot
of girls that don't feel good about
themselves and don't feel beautiful and
so I want to put in my music things that
inspire them to believe that they are
amazing
[Music]
natural
[Music]
she's not going buzz' she's gonna win
the whole thing
Amanda told me she looked up to her
favorite singers like Whitney Houston
and yes Aretha Franklin to gain
confidence but more than anything she
just wants to be a person she could be
proud of you got plenty to be proud of
girl we'll see you at the live shows but
you know Amanda hasn't been the only
inspiring young person to grace that
AGT stage with her talents 14 year old
rapper flage I moved Simon and the rest
of the judges on a GT with her original
song about gun violence the Georgia
native moved on to the next round but as
I found out her audition was more than
just about competing she had an
important message to share if he would
have put that gun down then he would
have been here right now and if he would
have put that gun down then she would
have been here right now
you're only 14 and yet you come out
there with an original song got away
with a really really powerful message
what were you hoping people took away
from your performance I just hope people
you know they understand that you can
you can handle situations different like
you don't have to you don't have to you
know in the situation with guns or you
don't have to in the situation with
killing people because people are dying
like left and right you know what I mean
so you know to have been witness that in
my life that my dad died and he was shot
and he was murdered you know that
affects me you know when I need a father
figure in my life you know and you know
it's kind of scary you know school
shooting you know school shootings in
churches you know it's it's like it's
really scary at a point where it's like
oh my god what's going on cuz it's
something that affects everybody no
matter what age you are yeah and sadly
it's a reality for a lot of young people
right now there's baby yeah it is
because a rapper
x-x-x he just died like and that like
stunned me like that hit me because like
oh my god yeah I was like are you
serious like is this like Roo and
everybody I didn't even know until like
somebody was tagging me they were like
[ __ ] classified look at this and they
were like and they were and I just I
just posted it and I was like hashtag
guns down yeah like he spread that
message people
to understand that you know just put the
guns down I'm telling you this young
woman is wise beyond her years and she
said she really was affected by xxx
contest she owns death which made the
message behind her song guns down that
much more important but you know flaw
she isn't the only one still reeling
from x-x-x death the 20 year old rapper
was shot and killed in South Florida
after a gunman reportedly ran up to his
vehicle as he was leaving a motorcycle
dealership and opened fire so far no
arrests have been made and on Tuesday
hundreds of fans gathered on Melrose in
Los Angeles for an impromptu memorial
for the slain rapper now local reporters
said the crowd turned rowdy though
climbing on a roof tops and swarming
moving cars before police ordered them
to leave at its peak the streets were
reportedly flooded with up to a thousand
people the music community took to
social media after news of ex's death
Kanye tweeted rest in peace I never told
you how much you inspired me when you
were here
thank you for existing of course we have
more on that story at ET online and more
what those America's Got Talent
standouts and we'll have more AG tegu
tease for you guys next week so until
then come back tomorrow I'll be here see
them